one person said like how can you do up
an experiment with one person i say
demonstrated to you in one person they
give me anybody right so and
nobody would put money against me and
say who's gonna put money against uh oh
i'm gonna give suga to just bring him
anybody he wants from anywhere in the
world
and i give them sugar and they're going
to have insulin go up
right so hello and welcome to the
chicken science show where in this video
i had the absolute pleasure to interview
professor volta longu
director of the longevity institute at
the university of southern california
as well as the program on longevity and
cancer
at the institute on molecular oncology
in milan
falter lungo well known for designing
the fasting mimicking diet
after making a series of remarkable
discoveries in mice
and then in humans that indicate that
specific diets can activate cellular
self-repair mechanisms
and promote rejuvenation in multiple
organisms to optimize health
here we chat more about his research
work and his future plans
so hi photo thank you very much for
joining me today and
welcome to the cheeky science show it's
an absolute pleasure to have you with me
i pleasure maybe thank you so
your research focuses on understanding
um how diet composition and diet timing
um and the underpinning mechanisms can
be
used to help further understand
longevity and help to treat different
diseases
and i guess you summarize a lot of this
information and you're really excellent
but for longevity diet
which i recommend for anyone that they
should definitely read that book
um and one of the kind of quotes that
i'm probably going to create wrong from
the book
is that you mentioned how um because we
all eat foods a lot of us think we know
that we often think we're diet experts
and we know what the best thing to eat
is
but actually in your book you use a very
logical approach and you
you use what you call the five pillars
of longevity
to come up with your idea of an ideal
longevity diet
and so i was wondering if you'd be able
to explain what these these five
different pillars are and
how you use that to come up with your
longevity diets i realize that's quite
the question but um
it's yeah yeah no no thanks uh
yeah so i always thought that it was
strange that in a courtroom
we will use all these different uh
pillars
if you will right to convict someone um
beyond a reasonable doubt and you know
and but in in science
in something so fundamental um for
human health i mean we all recognize
nutrition can completely change
uh whether somebody is going to make it
to 50 or 100
and so and and i thought how strange
that we
most people use epidemiology for example
um
to to make a decision right about food
and and so
so of course i thought well what what is
really important right
after spending 30 years working with
some of the best in the world
on uh i thought
epidemiology so the study of population
is definitely important so that's one
one big pillar right so what happens
with lots of people
um whether they eat this way or that way
you know with lots of proteins low
protein how do they
how do they perform and then um
studies of clinical studies i thought
were very important kind of like
um you know we'll be talking about the
um
high fat low fat for cardiovascular
disease for a long time
and then you have studies like the the
asterisk study that looks at
thousands of people and they're either
put on a low fat diet or a high
olive oil diet and you know within five
years you're starting to see the
difference right
so i thought that's really nice study
that that brings the clinical studies to
hey no it's probably not
bad to have fat if that fat is olive oil
and if you have you know if you're
beginning having cardiovascular disease
and then you know basic science uh focus
on longevity you know so
what happens with mouse if they have a
high fat diet or low fat diet or high
protein
and not just mice but you know what if
you look at all kinds of organisms what
is the role of amino acids and proteins
in making a an organism
live longer or shorter um so that
that's also very important and uh and
then centenarians you know so what about
you know we if we have all these and we
put them together we come up with
something
but then uh it would be nice to see the
lots of people that live a long life uh
use something similar or something makes
sense right so
so if you say low protein diet
seems to be associated with benefits in
all these different pillars
and then you look at centenarians and
none of them have a low protein diet
then you have to wonder that's strange
why why don't they you know if
it's so positive and but sure enough you
see them
having a most of them have little
protein that it's not all of them
and then the fifth pillar is a complex
systems um
you know so i i thought that you know
the reductionist approach is also very
important
sometimes you don't have you don't have
data um
so i one thing i i always mention you
know if you
there's some data but not not easy to
interpret so
is it good to go running all the time is
it good to run 100 miles a week
right and some people say yes and and
and and then well what about the
opposite it's good to not run at all
right
so if you look at a car or a plane i
think most people
recognize that any system that is
complicated
complex you know like a plane or or the
space shuttle
you can keep it there and not use it
but you cannot also use it all the time
right so nobody is going to want to buy
a car with 300 000 miles on it why not
you could say well it's been very very
used all the time
well almost guaranteed that that car is
going to have parts that are about to
break apart you know so
so yeah so that's that those are the
abilities
thank you yeah um and i really like the
way that you use the five pillars as i
think it is as you say a very logical
way of
using the different pieces of evidence
and playing them all together
um but correct me if i'm wrong but i
think probably the basic research pillar
is probably the
like the largest pillar we have at the
moment in terms of evidence
and so i mean what would you consider
are the the strongest pieces of evidence
we have supporting
let's say low protein or um high fat and
dietary components for the longevity
diets that you mentioned
i think it's um i mean i think it's
pretty even right
so the longevity diet um
in is if you think about the everyday
diet
there's a lot of you know
epidemiological data
um supporting um
either the safety of let's say a low
protein diet
or with a certain composition say 0.8
grams per kilogram per day
or or the efficacy in that diet making
making people live longer you know so
there's uh our studies and
several harvard studies and and just on
and on i think if you put
lots of epidemiological uh
studies together you come up with um
you're never gonna come up with
something that is perfect that doesn't
have any studies
against it but uh you come up with a lot
of support for it so for example
i was very happy to see recently
um i always talked about you know vegan
diets
being um potentially dangerous for
for not that not because they cannot be
done
because they're hard to do correctly
and it was interesting that a new paper
came out and showed that
epidemiological data showed that vegans
were
two and a half times more likely to have
fractures
hip fractures i think it was than
carnivores
but pescetarians did not in fact in most
cases there was a trend for pescatarians
to be lower
than the carnivores right so so yeah
that is the um the the sort of the
common denominator that i look for
i mean if you look at the pescetarian
diet uh
over you know low protein pescetarian
lots of vegetables not so much fruit you
know
it's really a very particular type of
diet you don't see too many things
against it right
and that's what i look for and same
thing for let's say 12 hours of
time receipt to eating versus 16 hours
if you look at 16 hours you find a lot
of negatives right
if you don't eat for 16 hours a day lots
of negatives
if you don't eat for 12 hours a day i
could never find a single negative study
and that's really what i focus on you
know is there like this
sort of jewel of uh
interventions that you can never find
something
that anybody says wrong something wrong
about that right
uh so i never heard anybody saying no i
discourage the pescetarian diet
because you know there is not enough
proteins like
fish we all recognize it's got a lot of
proteins a lot of
essential amino acids um very different
from the vegan right
so yeah so that that's really uh what i
was looking for i was looking for
things that are so solid it's just
almost like
impossible to take them apart you could
always find something better eventually
but i thought it's just very unlikely
that you're gonna find something
much better anytime soon you know that's
good to hear because i
i pretty much mainly follow a
pescetarian diet
forget about that um but i think one of
the i mean i'm probably biased because
most of my research
is basic research um like the
fundamental um
like by a chemical level and i guess
what i love about
your research and the research of others
is that these different studies have
not only identified different dietary
compositions that
um like have been shown to
help extend health span but also
underpin like the biochemical components
for example um there's been work that's
shown how
um following these diets or having low
protein diets reduce the activity of
components such as
mtor and reduced igf-1 levels
as i was just wondering if you could
explain a bit or elaborate on these
so-called longevity signaling pathways
and what your understanding of them are
yes so so most people to this day
and i would say lots of epidemiologists
they just look at the math right they
just say well you know this is what it
is i have no idea why
i just know that people they eat this
way they do better
than people eat that way and i think
that um you know we need to move to
hypothesis driven
um you know um recommendations
um and uh why well because
yeah you need to put it all together and
um
and i think the the nutrition response
genes tell a story that is much much
much clearer
than the one that you get by saying i
don't know why
lots of protein seems to be doing good
and um
because at a certain point and this is
why the fda usually doesn't
allow you to go forward unless you have
some good degree of mechanisms
in animal studies right it's going to
say well you think you know
but you don't really know and you know
what if you were wrong about this you
know so once you have the mechanisms
um once you say well i know this drug
lowers cholesterol and i know the
cholesterol
is involved in adorama formations and
and you know atherosclerosis etc
well yeah okay now you have a story and
that the role of of that drug
is much more believable uh and yeah i
know the high cholesterol is associated
with higher cardiovascular disease you
put it all together
and yeah so so the genes the the
nutrient response genes then tell the
story because alone they can
extend the lifespan of all kinds of
organisms right
so if you say taurus is kinase
is if you say amino acids activate igf-1
and also activate toruses kinase
independently by gf1
and this extends longevity and this
shortens longevity
uh or lifespan um well then
we already know that just by blocking
um taurus by deleting or by inhibiting
taurus's kinase
we can extend longevity so it's hard
much harder to argue against that right
say well
that alone does it we forget that you
can keep the diet the same
and um yeah so they become very very
very important
and um and and i think
the the signal the nutritional signaling
genes are very important
but even more important is what i call
you know
three billion years of rnd uh which is
evolution right
and they and i always i teach my
students
to look at yeast for example yeast can
live in the fast lane for a few days
or it can live for 17 days in stationary
phase in water
or it can live for a couple years as a
sport right
so now imagine um if you
wanted to go from a to c let's say a
couple days
to two years right so it's a hundreds of
fold uh difference
um you could go crazy with all this
reasoning right
or you could say hey wait a minute i
think the the organism already knows
right
i think already has a program in there
that allows it to go from two days to
two years it's like
that's crazy right so why does the the
queen bee
live for you know
orders of magnitude more than the worker
bee right um
well you could spend all your life
trying to figure out this the
the nutrient signaling pathways because
they eat different food and then they
they have a different developmental
program
or you could say let me just activate
the queen bee program
and uh and and switch to this you know
incredible lifespan so yeah i think that
part is more even more important
i mean understanding the signaling genes
is is key
but even more important understanding
the program the longevity programs
uh that's that's really um
at the center of the the fasting
and the you know restrictions uh and and
lots of the things that we publish in
the past you know
almost 30 years exactly and as you kind
of already
just alluded to um the real like one of
the great ways of
understanding like the underlying
mechanisms is that you can then
see how different interventions have a
similar impact and so obviously you just
mentioned their fasting
and how it's not just about the diet's
composition but also
diet timing can also in a similar way
activate or repress these different
signaling pathways
and so um you coined
um the fasting mimicking diet and so
i was wondering if you could explain
about how you came to
create this diet and how it relates to
fasting and also going back to
um activating these longevity programs
yes so the
the fasting week in diet people
sometimes think you know just woke up in
the morning and come up with
with this and just become my favorite
project
but in fact you know as i was a student
at roy walford back in 1992 and roy was
this guru
of nutrition and longevity right that's
all he spent his life trying to figure
out you know how to make people
live longer with nutrition and i
realized that
you know what he was doing color
restriction so what if you take an
organism and you take about 20 30
percent of the calories away
and i realized that had obviously
incredible
uh power but incredible problems
associated with it and so then i spent
the next
almost 30 years um trying to figure out
um how can you get that incredible power
you know and
without the problems and and making it
feasible to people
um and but then i started working with
bacteria
and yeast they were starving and i saw
that you could completely starve a
bacteria
or a yeast and they live very long and i
thought this is really strange right
it's very counterintuitive it's like why
would any organism live so long
just completely complete absence of
nutrients
but then i started thinking what if we
just did it very quickly
or quickly for a few days and then allow
the system to go back to the normal food
you know
and um yeah they worked very well and
they initially
initially was just water only fasting uh
for let's say
five days every couple weeks and or four
days every couple weeks
and then eventually went to fasting
making diet uh
in mice as little as once a month or
five days
and uh and in people now we think you
know it could be as little as
once every three months um and and why
is a
festive american diet well we started
doing a cancer clinical trial at usc
norris cancer center
and and this had water-only fasting and
um and nobody none of the patient wanted
to do water only fasting
and we thought of course i mean our
naive
uh group of scientists and oncologists
thought of course people are gonna do
water only fasting they have cancer
they're very motivated right this was
the reason
and it doesn't work like that right so
even with cancer people say
i don't i i just don't i'm not convinced
by this i don't want to do it
it's too hard um yeah so then then we
went back to the national cancer
institute and the national student aging
and asked to you know develop the
fasting mimicking diet
for cancer patients and this was
developed for constipation
and and then realized that you know with
the
if you have a dietitian and a fasting
making diet then you can get a very high
compliance
no thank you for explaining that so you
mentioned the clinical trials and i was
just wondering like obviously i guess
um one big question is um
how like safe would um implementing
fasting mimicking diets be
and then for the rest of your life and i
was just wondering like what is the
longest
uh trial that you've done so far or are
in the process of
of uh doing um to see
um how many times fmd can be done and
like looked at more long-term
safety consequences
yeah so um we are about to publish a
paper that also includes a survey
of thousands of patients or
doctors of i think 400 doctors that
follow thousands of patients
and the good news which is kind of
surprising we really
seen rarely even people
ending up in the hospital right and now
once it gets to thousands of people you
you expect that you know some people
by chance will will end up with with
grade 3 4 uh side effects but we really
are not seeing that so that's the
biggest um
that's the biggest um evidence i think
coming from
all the people that are doing it out
there um
and some people have been doing it for
years and and so far
i mean you usually hear i think the
company is also
obliged to report it right so uh to the
fda so
should somebody have you know severe
side effects um
yeah so so far we haven't seen it that
doesn't mean that
there couldn't be some but uh we haven't
seen it so i would say that
that seems to be very safe and it was
also designed to be
that so it wasn't designed lots of times
we get people to say why why don't you
have less
sugar why don't you have less starches
why don't you have
you know um less calories etc
and uh and and part of the the
development
of the of the fasting making diet for
for everybody
not for cancer patients but for for
everyone was to
um get a little bit less of an effect
and more safety uh thinking of
um you know what if everybody did this
you know let's say
between age 20 and age 70
we the burden is to
if you if you want to take a healthy
person
and um you know you're working on aging
right so so no matter
what we come up with um if you intervene
on a sick person there is a certain
degree
of tolerance for side effects right so
hey if you have cancer if alzheimer's
yes somebody could die even because of
the therapy
but there's nothing you can do but if
somebody's healthy right
then you have a different problem a
different burden
and you have to make sure almost nobody
ever dies
so or even almost nobody ever has severe
uh side effects and and that's that's a
very difficult that's a very
high um high
burden and yeah but that's what we've
been focusing on
uh making it so that um that
we rarely really see see problems with
it
exactly and i mean as you mentioned
earlier one of the reasons that
um you created the fasting mimicking
diet is to kind of
avoid some of their more deleterious
effects of doing water any fasting
which could lead to malnourishment and
one thing that i find quite interesting
and you had a paper i think came out in
2019
which is how fasting can influence the
gut microbiome
and obviously the gut microbiome feeds
off like fiber that we
consume in our diets and so and
sometimes in my head the thought of
doing
a water only fasting makes me think
what's going on with my the gut
microbiome
have they got any foods and so obviously
you showed in
that study i believe it was looking at
how fmd
kids alleviate symptoms of inflammatory
bowel syndrome
and so i was just wondering like to what
extent do you think some of the benefits
of
fmd are being mediated by the gut
microbiome and what part do you think
they play in the whole process
yeah so um the original idea because
walford
was and lots of people that i work with
were always fans of either vegan diets
or pescatarian diet in this longevity
areas around the world
you know the okinawa so i i thought from
the very beginning i want to melt
i don't want to do a fasting mimicking
diet with any ingredient i want to do a
fashion vegan diet mimicking diet
with the ingredients the longest lived
people in the world
eat all the time and and you know
you could have argued with me it's like
that makes no sense because you just
giving it to them for five days
once in a while while you do it with the
use
meat use red meat use
use lard right use animal products
yeah but i thought no i wanna i think
we eventually we're gonna see benefits
from using the right ingredients
and you know that paper was one of the
first ones showing that
water only fasting actually made the gut
more
of mice more leaky right and it makes
sense right because the mice after not
having food for a while
uh they start breaking down
lots of cells they don't need as much
right so if you have just
water you can break down the gut and the
leakiness increases
and um but with the fasting making dye
which contains a lot of vegetable
a lot of prebiotic um we didn't see that
right so there's probably enough food in
the gut plus
this feeding of of these lactobacillus
bifidobacteria etc
it was probably sufficient that we saw
this big expansion
these protective microbes and
um and we don't know but i mean there's
lots of papers that are now are
suggesting that yes if you go from
whatever 15 to 60 protective
bacteria species then you you could be
expected to have benefits for
inflammatory bowel disease or general
inflammation of the gut
so now we have you know number of
clinical trials that
that are looking at exactly that uh
stanford is actually now taking the lead
in doing the uh the studies so we'll see
what happens but um
but now we're sort of combining this
idea of the fasting
with the idea of feeding the
microbes right so fasting while feeding
um
and uh and i think that that's very
important and also the the pulse
fasting feeding is important so what
would
fad during the fast but it was also fad
after the fast that is probably driving
you know the microbes one way or another
so if you eat a steak
um this could be killing a lot of the
effects
of the the five days of the of the vegan
diet right so
um yeah so that's why we we also think
that at least 24 hours
past the fmd should be lots of
vegetables maybe a little bit of fish
um and that's it you know and make like
cereals
a little bit of fish and lots of
vegetables i'm glad you mentioned that
because that was actually my next
question was to talk about
the refeeding process as the the last
stop the last stage after the
the five days or so of the the fasting
mimicking diet
and the reason i wanted to ask you about
it was obviously
what i researched in a lab is cellular
senescence and
um i think it's thought that obviously
the
the fasting stage to fight this fasting
might help to
clear potentially senescent cells and i
was gonna ask you if you had any strong
evidence to support that
the senescent cells are being cleared
but then um more in from that
the mentioning how there's currently a
bit of um
controversy over the therapeutic use of
senalytics
and how some concerns are that analytics
just clear the cells without
reactivating stem cells to
regenerate tissue and so i was wondering
if you think maybe
therefore the fasting mimicking diet
with the refeeding process as well
may potentially be more superior in
terms of having both
um the clearance of synesthetic cells
but also the activation of stem cells
and what evidence there is for that
yeah i think the the main thing is what
i was saying earlier right uh
about billions of years of r d right so
so the bio hacking i think is fine as
long as
very very aware of uh what's always been
there for the purpose of of
something and um and i we're starting to
suspect that
when you when you start any organism
from bacteria all the way to
to humans when you starve any organism
and it makes a lot of sense if you think
about it and not not
the the everything that makes sense is
true but
so you start with an organism this
organism is forced to shrink
essentially and and in the shrinking
process
it could do two things it could um
uh eat anything right
of itself it's gonna eat some of itself
it's gotta you know
consume less energy so so you know
it has to get rid of some energy
consuming
uh components cells mostly
but um it also has to eat itself
and so in this process of in itself it
could pick anything
or it could go pick the worst things
that there are right
and kill those right and and you think
you know
is it possible after three billion years
that an organism whether it's a bacteria
or a human being
in that moment that is shrinking itself
uh and it's getting rid of billions and
billions of cells
is gonna go or at least shrinking
billions and billions of cells
it's just gonna not care what it picks
right
it's i think it's extremely unlikely
it's much more likely that
like in development when we develop
there is a lot of apoptosis and
apoptosis
is looking for bad components and good
components right
so we already know we have that system
we
the human body and the mouse they can
pick and choose
what's good what's bad and um so now you
you're shrinking um and now food comes
around and you have enough food
enough proteins enough sugars to you
know
regrow and uh and so now
you again you're regrowing well what are
you gonna do
you could pick any stem cell any cell
out there or you could say
okay let me pick the best one right
and let me use the best one as a
template to start over and let me not
just use the best cell
let me use what i already know from
embryonic development
right let me just use a program
that is already been there from the
beginning why not
you know we the genetic material is in
there the epigenetic
um information are there also
why don't you use that you know how to
use it use it right and that's exactly
what we see right so you see the
expansion
you look at the the embryonic
development genes and they're
all light up right and these are not
usually
seen in adults at all right so and now
how can you see
nano again oxford and all of these just
lighting up in all kinds of organs right
yeah so
i mean it's hard to demonstrate these
things all the way but
we're now seeing in in the pancreas
we see in the liver we see it in the in
the
somewhat in the brain we see it now we
see it in
in so many in the gut um so now you
start again in the picture
it's probably part of the of this
evolved program
to you know get rid of the damaged
components
turn on the cellular and stem cell
factors that can then
rebuild right so yeah so that that
that's really the the
focus is the um um you know
and in the process of course if you have
senescent cells
that's bad right so that's that's
something that the system will recognize
as bad uh now we've been working on it
for a while and we're
about to start a clinical trial on that
and um
so we're looking at all of that and
we'll see what happens but um
but uh you know hopefully we'll see a
reduction of
asynolytic effect of
fasting megan dieter yeah you're saying
that really well and
i'm very excited to see that research um
so um another thing i wanted to ask you
about
was um epigenetic changes that might be
occurring
um during fasting or fasting mimicking
diets um
and the potential um i think you you saw
in one study i think it was in mice that
um even after doing a couple of months
of the fmds
you saw that there was like a kind of
memory of the
the process such that levels of like
igf-1 still remains low and i was
wondering if you've
done any studies in humans while you've
maybe looked at different epigenetic
marks and
or even i um have interest in doing like
an epigenetic age for
patients that have undergone fmd to see
how that might be correlating
with um like the biological age and
whether fmd can have an impact on that
yes yes so we are about to publish
in collaboration with morgan levine um
a yale about the the biological age um
algorithm that she uses which is based
on
in our case seven markers blood markers
um that uh that are associated with a
particular
um you know chance of dying in the next
however many years so we're about to
publish on that
and then uh we are about to start
soon enough with with steve orbot we're
about to start um
you know looking at um we're looking
both at the
people that are genetically the
ecuadorians that we've been following
the
mutation the growth hormone receptor and
the fasting
making diet and looking at the
epigenetic clock
and we'll see what happens uh um in
those studies but
yeah we're we're um close to starting
both yeah
oh cool that's really exciting i'll be
on the lookout for that as well
um so i guess yeah another question that
um i was interested is going back to
some of your earlier work and using
uh yeast as a muscle organism um and
one thing um as well from my own
interest is that
um my phd project focuses on the protein
p53
and i might be wrong but i'm pretty
certain that you don't have
the homologue of p53 and so i was
wondering um do you think there's any
involvements or p53
in any of the effects of fasting or fmds
or diet composition and whether in use
there's like some alternative mechanism
that they just don't need this protein
or what are your thoughts on it
now p53 is definitely very central
in the fasting effects in mammals so we
publish several papers particularly in
cancer
but probably probably involved
in both the cancer progression but also
the cancer incidence and maybe
you know the aging process itself p53
may very well be also involved in
what i was saying earlier i wouldn't be
surprised if one of the
um if one of the genes that are
involved in deciding who gets killed
and who does not is p53 right
um so so yeah so we see it as
very central uh yeah yeast doesn't have
at least as
as older genes and pathways that
maybe precursors to uh to p53
and and the tumor suppressors but um
but uh i think you know i i i like to
call it molecular strategy
i think the molecular strategy is very
similar uh but
uh you know so ease doesn't have insulin
doesn't have igf-1
it's a unicellular eukaryote that does
not need insulin igf-1 it does not have
an endocrine
system so while you know yeah so i think
b53
um there are
molecular strategies that are very
similar in yeast
and um it just happen to not
yeah probably need the the
sophistication of p53
and so with the day with i guess
different muscle organisms being
um more available say things like
cyberfish and um
and um axolotls and all sorts of
different muscle organisms now
do you still feel like there's a place
for yeast um
what are your thoughts on that we don't
do almost anything if it doesn't start
from east right so
uh i mean every clinical trial we've
ever done
every you know everything we do usually
starts with these
um yeah so i think that the beauty
um i think is the fundamental
uh property of an organism right so
so you know the starvation response and
all the all our cancer work is a hundred
percent based on our yeast work you know
it started because of east you know they
started because of seeing that
you know the starvation causes
these transcription factors being
elevated
but if you introduce a a ras vowel
19 mutation in yeast
um this effect went away right and that
was it there was a whole
a whole you know big operation on you
know many clinical trials
uh on uh you know what's called
differential stress resistance
and um yeah so i think that that's a
mistake not to have
a simple model organism uh
nearby and um and just ask
it's almost like you know so somebody
they're very wise that you can ask
questions
to uh well how do you think this works
is there a way to distinguish all cancer
cells from all normal cells
and i think um you know the yeast is
probably
it's so simple that it just gives you a
real answer
it doesn't give you like you're in any
complex organism you have a million
answers like oh it could be this it
could be that it could be a million
different things
and yes it's just that's it you know by
the end of it it's like okay
i know how it works it's this right uh
so yeah so that's you know so of course
you know worms and flies and different
different
organisms i think model organism have a
different
place but uh but yeast is definitely
uh and not surprising the so many
nobel prizes right were given for
working yeast you know
our bacteria like including the recent
ones right you know
the moment you think that
some of these organisms are no longer
valuable and then you get crisper
you know casino and you're like okay
well
here we go again you know another
another study done
in very very simple organisms you know
so
very good answer um so talking about uh
research questions
um to you what do you think are the the
biggest
um unanswered research questions we have
at the moment
um or to phrase a better way what um
research questions are you most
interested in in for the future
well we're very interested in uh you
know now that we
are um seeing this
you know reactivation of embryonic
developmental programs
uh we're very interested in that right
so are you how do you guide that
is there a way to intervene is there a
way to you know control it more
you know can you do it in the brain
right can you can you do something like
that in a brain you know maybe
you know we could we could take you know
the
mouse pancreas and damage it where it
makes no more insulin then we start with
the cycles the fmd
and we see that the pain the beta cells
being starting to be
regenerated in this beautiful solar
program but
can you actually do this in in in a much
tougher
uh system like the brain and you know
could you do it when the brain is
damaged
in a mouse let's say alzheimer's or
or parkinson and could you do it in a
person now we have a clinical trial in
italy running
with alzheimer's disease and um and
fasting making diet so
um this is very interesting right so is
it possible that
you know we don't even need that is like
sort of like a black box effect
where you know it just works and then we
could take our time
you know figuring out how it works but
uh it could also be that no
you know the black box effect is not
there we need to figure out exactly how
it works
and um and uh but but but that's gonna
need some
kind of like we see for cancer right in
cancer we
we've never been able to i always say
i've never been able to cure
any mice with fasting alone right or
fasting making that long
it's always like fasting plus plus or
plus
plus plus right so the last last one for
example with hormone therapy
is fasting plus estrogen receptor
blocker
plastic basically right and the only
reason we could do that is
is by the molecular understanding of um
of you know how the cancer cells is
wired
and or and or rewired once it becomes
resistant right so
yeah so then yeah i think the future
we're looking at
black box effect but also as we
get more and more and more sophisticated
with with molecular
biology biology but also omics you know
computational biology now if you start
putting all these omics together
and maybe using artificial intelligence
and uh can you
can you now start gaining uh more of an
understanding of the programs that are
involved in
in you know making an organism younger
and speaking of different amex
technologies um what are your thoughts
on
precision medicine or i guess in this
case precision nutrition
and what kind of like biomarkers or data
do you think
we'll need to really uh get to that
stage because you mentioned in your book
how
you should like kind of eat like your
ancestors and how certain reasons you
might be allergic to different foods and
i'm just wondering
what information um do we need to
understand
why someone might be allergic to a satin
food and stay away from that or you
should eat this this is best for you
for the future yeah so i think we need
both precision
precise medicine and unprecise medicine
right
we everybody likes to go to the precise
and in cancer we see the the
the example right so i hit the cdk46
pathway with paul boseklib but then i
have the unprecise medicine of fasting
that in in that case hit insulin igf-1
and leptin
you know all three um so yeah so then
then you know the precise medicine is
necessary why you know somebody from
japan
that has been you know lactose
intolerant for
for hundreds of years in families
um you know they're gonna move to the
united states and start
drinking a lot of milk they're not
guaranteed but they probably have a high
chance of
you know becoming lactose intolerant so
if you have celiac
disease and you're just loaded with
bread and pasta uh you're gonna have a
problem right so
yeah so i think we we can recognize that
um
that our precision medicine is very very
important
and uh but at the same time we also have
to recognize that
unprecise medicine as as important so i
was like what we call
evolutionary medicine you know looking
at i always say
um you know bring me a person to whom i
can give
sugar that they will not have an insulin
response right
uh so you could do an experiment of one
person right and get it right
if it was just like i could show you
that uh in response to sugar insulin is
going to go up
say give me anybody i'll show you one
person say like how can you do
an experiment with one person i say
demonstrated to you in one person they
give me anybody
right so and nobody would put money
against me and say who's gonna put money
against uh oh i'm to give sugar to just
bring him anybody you want from anywhere
in the world
and i give them sugar and they're going
to have insulin go up
right and uh yeah so so that's the
unprecise medicine i'm talking about you
know with
fasting and so there's some things that
are just gonna be
very very similar to almost anybody you
can pick in the world
you know some people do not respond with
insulin to sugar right so yeah
but there's probably one in a hundred
thousand or something like that
um so so yes for the green majority of
the people
um the unprecise medicine is as
important so yeah i think
we're gonna have to move forward with
both of these
um you know saying what's what's common
between a bacteria and a human
right on one side and then what's only
common to you
then and that you where you are celiac
and you have this mutation and you just
happen
to not or or have your immune system
attack
um the the gluten um
you know component of the food
i think that's a really great way to
kind of summarize um our conversation
um it's been absolutely fascinating to
talk to you and i hope um well i'm sure
many of my viewers will have found it
fascinating as well
so i just really appreciate the time
you've taken today to talk to me
well thank you you're very welcome great
thank you very much so i hope you've
learned something in this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening